est-ce que je vais me faire vacciner
c'est la question que la france se pose
est ce que cyrus north va se faire
vacciner et sound of gaming vaccine min
et miley cyrus north vaccine in cyrus
neuf et très lié vaccine mérode y en a
mais roth et voilà la bourse n'est pas
évidente et comme beaucoup d'entre vous
je me pose des questions
des questions qui sont légitimes alors
il ya juste que vous trouverez pas dans
cette vidéo
exemple vous trouverez pas de jugement
vous trouverez pas non plus de
malhonnêteté intellectuelle et au
contraire vous allez trouver je l'espère
de l'ouverture des questions et des
réponses
en fait à travers cette vidéo je vous
expliquais mon cheminement de pensée
quand je me suis intéressé à cette
question là voilà je me suis dit autant
en faire profiter le plus grand nombre
quoi
quitte à faire des recherches autant que
ça sert voilà le vaccin qui arrivent
mais son temps il met son temps mais il
arrive et on a le choix de se vacciner
ou non
je pense que c'est déjà intéressant de
rappeler c'est quoi un vaccin en fait un
vaccin c'est qu'on nous injecte une
version affaibli du virus pour que le
corps réagissent et que la prochaine
fois qu'il rencontre le virus en vrai eh
bien ils soient prêts parce qu'il pense
qu'il aura déjà connu une attaque qu'en
fait vous a compris ce n'est pas
vraiment une attaque à ce jour à
l'échelle de l'humanité
les vaccins nous ont permis de maîtriser
plein de maladie par exemple la
diphtérie la variole la fièvre jaune la
coqueluche la polio la rougeole et le
tétanos toutes ces maladies elles ne
sont plus dans notre quotidien
grâce au vaccin moi même je suis vacciné
contre plein de maladies 4 que ces
vaccins ont déjà sauvé la vie j'en sais
rien en tous les cas je remercie mes
parents pour ça maintenant je vais
parler vite fait des risques liés aux
vaccins sous fond en parler vous essayez
de comprendre pourquoi il ya autant de
gens qui sont contre les vaccins ou qui
est en tout cas sont réfractaires
tous les médicaments ils ont des effets
secondaires la plupart des effets
secondaires ils sont bénins et
apparaître le vaccin ça va être sympa
une irritation ça être une petite fièvre
ce genre de trucs voilà mais ce qui nous
intéresse et les effets secondaires qui
sont plus graves et ceux qui sont
réfractaires au vaccin souvent parle de
par exemple l'autisme ou la sclérose en
plaques pour l'autisme en fait il ya une
étude de 98 qui crée un lien entre le
vaccin et robert donc au
jol oreillons rubéole et l'autisme
depuis cette étude toutes les études ont
montré que en fait il n'y a pas de lien
entre ce vaccin et l'autisme l'étude de
80 digital a même été retiré et il faut
savoir pour vous donner un peu plus de
contexte que voilà l'étude de 98 elle a
été menée sur douze enfants
il ya une étude par exemple qui l'a
discrédité en 2006 qui a été menée sur
vingt-huit mille enfants canadiens 12
enfants d'un côté 28000 de l'autre voilà
comme je vous le dis tout les études
discrédite celles des douze enfants
mais entre guillemets le mal est fait
quoi parce que parce que dans la tête de
plein de genre ils se sont dit ah merde
ça cause l'autisme en fait non
voilà pour la sclérose en plaques
c'est lié notamment au vaccin de
l'hépatite b en fait il ya un moment on
a vacciné énormément de monde contre
l'hépatite b
il ya des gens qui ont développé une
sclérose en plaques en fait on attaque
c'est tellement de monde que on a
vacciné des gens qui allaient être
susceptibles de développer quoi qu'il
arrive en fait une sclérose en plaques
et je dis quoi qu'il arrive parce que
quand on regarde les statistiques et pas
plus de chance d'avoir une sclérose en
plaques en est vaccinée contre
l'hépatite b que quand on n'est pas
vaccinée contre l'hépatite b donc faut
pas confondre corrélation et causalité
il ya beaucoup de gens qui meurent dans
leur lit le lit n'est pas pour autant un
endroit dangereux
balla ya beaucoup de gens qui ont une
sclérose en plaques et qui ont été
vaccinés c'est pas pour autant que le
vaccin cause la sclérose en plaques
ah j'ai continué mes recherches il ya
d'autres vaccins par exemple est un
vaccin contre la dengue qui s'appelle le
deuil novaxia par sanofi qui lui a
priori a fait des morts notamment aux
philippines c'est un vaccin qui vraiment
dès les essais cliniques pu la merde
c'est difficile de comprendre pourquoi
elle a été autorisée là bas je vous mets
les liens en descriptions je rends pas
dans le détail mais à titre
d'information il n'a jamais été approuvé
en europe par exemple
donc c'est quelque part rassurant du
fait de voir que bah quand un vaccin est
naze ça se voit dès les essais cliniques
et que l'europe ne laisse pas passer
n'importe quoi alors que sanofi c'est
une boîte française donc on aurait pu
croire que non rien de tout ça après
c'est vrai que les trucs chelous dans le
vaccin par exemple l aluminium
on sait utiliser pour angle vaccins plus
efficaces etc bon j'avoue je me suis pas
attardé dessus dans la mesure où genre
quasiment tous les vaccins ont
l'aluminium depuis genre presque un
siècle quoi et ça a pas l'air de poser
problème
donc j'ai creusé un petit peu le truc
quand même apparemment la dose maximale
d'aluminium dans un vaccin c'est
horrible 85 mg et on en ingère via ce
qu'on consomme et c'est tous les jours
entre 3 et 6 mg dans notre alimentation
que cet argent par exemple il ya plus
d'aluminium dans une tablette de
chocolat que dans un vaccin est ce que
c'est pire que de fumer du goudron alan
nan men après même quand il ya des
gratte et il faut penser à la balance
bénéfice risque
par exemple en inde il ya une campagne
de vaccination contre la polio est en
fait dans chez certaines personnes
la version affaibli la polio elle a muté
et elle a paralysé la personne bon c'est
chiant les cas recensés ces 17 personnes
en dix sept ans sur des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de personnes
vaccinées
c'est comme le vaccin pandemrix contre
h1n1 en europe les 20 millions de
personnes qui ont été vaccinées
et sur ces 20 millions on a recensé 650
personnes qui sont un narco l'éthique
suite au vaccin c'est hyper chiant
d'être narcoleptique je suis bien
d'accord mais ça reste 650 personnes sur
20 millions encore une fois la balance
bénéfices risques est du côté du vaccin
tout ça c'est le vaccin normal voilà ça
j'avoue j'ai pas peur de le faire j'en
ai déjà plein dans mon corps
vraiment ça ça ne m'arrange pas là par
contre là c'est un vaccin développé déjà
hyper vite
en plus ces nouvelles technologies
on n'a pas trop trop testés et tous qui
s'appelle arn messagers enfin chelou
quoi ça ne pose question tout ça et du
coup j'ai essayé de me renseigner pour
comprendre mais comment ça marche
en fait les rênes message et c'est quoi
cette technologie etc j'ai compris et je
vais vous l'expliquer on a notre adn
l'adn en gros c'est une suite de gênes
d'accord chaque gène ça contient les
instructions nécessaires à la création
d'une protéine alors les protéines ça
sert à plein de choses ça sert pas
seulement à avoir des énormes pec comme
les miens qui je sais peuvent être un
petit peu oppressant je suis désolé pour
ça non ça sert aussi enfin tu vois c'est
les hormones ces enzymes des anticorps
s'est énormément de choses les protéines
comme une cellule avait créé une
protéine
elle prend le gène correspondant elle en
crée une copie à usage unique celle arn
messagers ça en fait et ensuite il ya
des ribosomes s'en fout de ce que c'est
ça s'appelle des ribosomes nageurs qui
décode la rn messager et qui le
transforme en une suite d'acides aminés
et gars soit une suite d'acides aminés
c'est une protéine donc de l'adn on tire
un arn messagers qu'on transforme en
protéines ça tout ça c'est ce qui se
passe naturellement et en fait les
chercheurs ils ont essayé de détourner
sans en gros ce qu'on a à faire c'est
qu'on va directement shooter de la rn
messager au ribosome qui eux vont le
décoder et créer une protéine et cette
protéine
c'est la protéine qui correspond au
virus une protéine qui va pas nous
rendre malade mais contre laquelle le
corps va pouvoir s'entraîner le point
ans à voir là dedans c'est que même si
j'ai utilisé le mot aden plein de fois
vous avez remarqué en fait ça ne touche
pas du tout l'adn ça ne modifie en rien
nos gènes ou quoi que ce soit en fait on
shoote directement un arn messager au
ribosome qui crée une protéine par les
avantages c'est quoi ce que les arn
messagers c'est un vaccin qui est plus
facile à produire le désavantage c'est
que c'est fragile la rn messager et donc
du coup sa demande à être conservés au
froid alors je vous avoue que déjà
comprendre tout ça ça me rassure
vachement déjà ça me rassure vachement
et d'ailleurs pour les flippés de
l'aluminium
il n'ya pas d'aluminium en fait dans le
vaccin files heures on n'a pas besoin
donc problème évacués à ce stade du coup
qu'est ce qui est qu'est ce qui pourrait
me faire flipper
il a beau se font un max de thune sur le
vaccin bah ouais je ne fais pas philippe
et j'avoue ça enfin c'est pas pour ça
que j'ai pas me faire vacciner quoi
temps autant mieux enfin je veux dire
s'ils sont en train de sauver des
millions de vies tant mieux pour eux qui
gagnent de l'argent qu'est-ce que
voulez-vous dix grâce au vaccin j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir relancer notre économie
les restaurants vont pas fermer etc pour
moi les théâtres les machins les signer
enfin bref
ok vous voyez ils vont se faire un max
de thune mois qu'ils se fassent un max
de thune pas une raison pour moi pour
flipper du vaccin en tout cas pareil
pour le côté comment on l'a eu aussi
vite suis pas vraiment suspicieux dans
la mesure où bahia vraiment con ça a été
une crise mondiale donc des équipes du
monde entier qui s'y sont mises et qui
ont partagé des connaissances sur le
génome et c'est entre l arn messagers
c'est une technologie qu'on travaille
depuis une décennie et qui permet de
dégainer un accès plus rapidement à une
technologie qui est quand même vachement
plus avancés qui a plusieurs années
quand vous et d'autres vaccins
on connaît bien la famille des
coronavirus je vous rappelle que voilà
il ya eu le sar ce le maire ce le machin
plein d'autres virus de même famille qui
nous ont fait pas mal de dégâts
ces dernières années et on a réduit
drastiquement les délais administratifs
pour les validations et c'est parce
qu'on est dans un contexte de crise donc
j'avoue quand on met tout ça bout à bout
je trouve pas ça déconne ans la partie
qui m'inquiète le plus c'est la partie
genre ok ok ça allait vite et je
comprends que soit l élite
mais du coup c'est quoi le recul qu'on a
sur ce vaccin en fait l'argent qu'on à 0
culture de vaccins même si je le
comprends et c'est ça me pose question
donc je me suis renseigné sur les études
qui ont été faites sur le vaccin est un
temps sur les essais cliniques etc
évidemment les comparaisons avec des
vaccins plus classique pour voir comment
les essais cliniques sont fait
d'habitude alors comment on fait pour
tester l'efficacité d'un vaccin les
effets secondaires etc
on prend deux groupes de personnes il ya
un groupe on leur file le vaccin on leur
injecte le vaccin et l'autre groupe
on leur injecte autre chose un placebo
ce que voulait pas vraiment ce que vous
voulez restons sur le placebo ensuite
ces deux groupes de personnes
il faut attendre qu'il y ait des gens
qui soient exposés à la maladie et qui
tombent malades
ok et comme ça on va pouvoir comparer ok
le nombre de malades qu'on a de chaque
côté et ça en vrai en temps normal ça
prend du temps quoi parce qu'on tombe
pas malade comme ça là avec le couronne
à virus vu qu' on est au milieu d'une
pandémie
massy en fait justement ces problèmes
c'est qu'on tombe malade comme ça très
mauvais claquement de doigts non c'est
un peu mieux je préfère faire comme ça
un truc iraniens savent albert kahn vous
l'apprendrez une autre fois arrêté arrêt
concentrez-vous plus concentré de
seconde c'est important la le vaccin
donc par exemple si on compare le vaccin
files heures contre qu'ovide et un
vaccin contre le pneumocoque
je sais même pas ce que c'est ce qui
s'appelle le prevenar on voit que ce qui
prend du temps c'est pas de monitorer
les effets secondaires etc
non c'est que des gens tombent malade
pour pouvoir vérifier l'efficacité du
vaccin ça vraiment ça m'a surpris parce
que moi je pensais que vraiment c'était
les effets secondaires qui prenaient du
temps etc et j'ai tilté
mais est ce qu'on va vous j'ai pas pensé
avant que et physiquement les effets
secondaires d'un vaccin
ça se passe genre dans dans les heures
les jours grand max semaines qui suivent
l'injection quoi et qu'en fait on ne
connaît aucun vaccin aujourd'hui août à
des effets secondaires un genre qui se
déclenchent j'ai pas à cinq ans plus
tard quoi tu vois et je trouve ça
logique
en y réfléchissant parce que c'est une
injection un moindre 20 juillet ce n'est
pas un traitement si c'était un
traitement que tu prenais georges pas un
médicament que tu prenais genre tous les
jours pendant des mois et des mois et
des années comme par exemple la pilule
est bien là je comprends le flip de des
effets long terme
là le vaccin c'est un shot à un moment
en fait donc tu vois genre y va pas y
avoir un truc qui va se réveiller cinq
ans plus tard il va au bois et à 5 ans
tu m'as fait un truc de bâtard la non en
fait moi j'ai pas vous mentir le vrai
truc qui me faisait flipper c'était les
effets secondaires long terme le fait
qu' il n'y a aucun vaccin qui a des
effets secondaires à long terme et qu'il
y ait cette logique qui je parlais de ça
après mais ça me sens fin voilà en tout
cas moi ça me parle ce truc que je me
fais
actionner un instant ce n'est pas un
traitement long cours etc et que du coup
les effets secondaires
s'ils arrivent ils sont dans les heures
les jours les semaines max et voilà bah
tout ça ça nous rassure énormément pour
les effets secondaires court terme
il y en a dans le vaccin files heure par
exemple
c'est mais c'est de l'or de l'allergie
quoi ces chocs anaphylactiques c'est
comme si j'imagine vous était allergique
aux cacahuètes et vous preniez une
bouchée de cacahuètes quoi genre se
passe pas joli joli à voir mais le
lendemain on vous traite et c'est le
lendemain c'est vrai bien les amis quel
est le pourcentage de gens qui ont des
problèmes allergiques et là je vous
donner des chiffres
évidemment on est là pour ça aux états
unis il ya eu six cas genre sur 270
mille doses et au royaume uni il ya eu
deux cas sur six cent mille doses
voilà donc en gros l'ordre de grandeur
de pourcentage c'est vrai que le 0 0 1%
voilà encore une fois c'est pas genre
c'est pas ce recul 0,1 pour cent de gens
qui meurent ces genres c'est au lit le
lendemain ça va bien il ya une personne
un plus et une aide soignante au
portugal qui est décédé à l'heure où
j'écris cette vidéo on sait pas trop
donc si c'est en lien avec le vaccin
ça arrivait genre le lendemain ou le
surlendemain du vaccin genre une morsure
mort subite quoi et on a de grosses
suspicion sur le fait que soit le vaccin
on attend de l'eau toxiques etc
mais même si ces deux vaccins
c'est une personne sûre on a déjà
vacciné des millions de gens en fait ça
me fait de la peine mais on s'en fout
enfin chut on s'en fout pas qu'elle
meure mais on s'en fout en termes de
statistiques de une personne versus 1
millions des millions de personnes qui
ont été vaccinées
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse l'étude sur
le vaccin files heure là qu'ils sont en
train distribuer en france etc
elle a été fait sur deux groupes de
vingt mille personnes
c'est énorme je vous mets le lien de
l'étude en descriptions personne ne la
lyre à personne peut-être une personne
va la lire je te remercie alors choix
qu'on se pose des questions sur les
enfants de moins de 16 ans et les femmes
enceintes
en fait c'est très simple c'est parce
qu'il n'était pas dans les essais
cliniques voilà on n'a pas fait des
essais sur eux donc c'est pour ça qu'on
se pose des questions sur eux mais pour
moi en étant ni un enfant de moins de 16
ans
une femme enceinte a priori pour moi
quand je lis tout ça quand je vous dis
tout ça quand je me renseigne surtout ça
y'a pas de risques extrêmement peu de
risque qu'il se passe quelque chose quoi
tout ça que quand je vois des graphiques
qui montrent que les français font
partie des plus réticents aux vaccins
que cet âge et je pouvais le comprendre
avant de faire toutes ces recherches là
maintenant que je les ai faites
en fait je si on a le même raisonnement
que moi on aboutit aux mêmes conclusions
et donc il n'y a aucune raison d'être
créatif par rapport à ça du coup la
dernière question que je me pose c'est
moi j'ai 30 ans ok j'ai 30 ans je suis
en bonne santé et cetera je touche du
bois
le coc vite ça a peu de chance de me
faire des dégâts du coup est ce que ça
vaut le coup que je me vaccine quoi à
cette question n a plus de sens en fait
puisqu'il ya pas de risque au vaccin
donc le risque du coc vide et forcément
supérieurs aux risques du vaccin et
vraiment de manière très honnête la
réponse à la question est ce que je me
faire vacciner évidemment oui en fait
oui ya aucune raison de ne pas se faire
vacciner à ce stade après tout ça je
parle de moi et des risques que je suis
prêt à prendre moi mais encore une fois
je le dis souvent les vidéos je suis pas
votre d'aaron j'espère que ces vidéos va
vous aider à faire votre choix
moi j'ai fait le mien faites le vôtre
vous êtes responsable moi je décline
toute responsabilité de quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs tout soit bien clair moi
c'est mon choix que je vous raconte là
c'est c'est ma compréhension du truc et
c'est tous les liens sont en
descriptions pouvez vous renseigner et
faire votre foi ou vous même vous êtes
responsable bon dieu vous êtes
responsable je sens vous inquiétez pas
au rythme auquel certains on sera
vacciné en 2001 2 donc vous aurez assez
de recul
vous pourrez voir venir n'hésitez pas
voilà en parler dans les commentaire
j'espère que ça va entonner des
dialogues bienveillant et voilà c'est
sous c'est tout ce que je souhaite pour
cette vidéo à vrai dire ça serait une
vidéo réussi pour moi si ça permet de
faire ça love peace ciao